the parents of a 14 year old girl killed  by police in a los angeles department  store are calling for justice this  morning valentina orianna peralta was  shopping with her mother when police  shot and killed a man who is assaulting  customers she was hit by a stray bullet  that pierced the wall of her dressing  room her mother described that moment  through an attorney  she died in my arms  and there was nothing i could do  to see a son or daughter die in your  arms  is one of the pains the greatest pains  and most profound pains that any human  being can imagine  no one should have to understand that  pain according to her family valentina  had moved to the u.s just six months ago  police have released edited video of the  incident including surveillance and body  cam footage the lapd calls the incident  quote tragic and devastating the officer  who killed her is on paid administrative  leave during this investigation